he obsessed yeah he but but focused he
wasn't one of these artists that let any
other people do it for him and then he
would get out there and dance to this
song and I'm like wow you know because I
grew up with the Jackson 5 and he wasn't
Michael Jackson at the time he was just
a member of The Jackson 5 and I this was
a band that had saved my ass so many
times when I was DJing afterwards he
took my card God and he said would you
do some parties for me and I said sure
So I go to his house on havenhurst in
Nino I've been there yeah yeah and I I
djed about 12 parties for Michael
Jackson did he pay well he paid well and
then I I did the uh launch party for the
tour and I had to be screened by the FBI
so I'm glad I had a green card at the
time